تحضيرات ودعوات من خطر انقسام المحتمل على
العالم باسره تبدا بها قمه اسيا اعمالها
حيث يلتقي قادته دول الرابطه لاول مره منذ
سنوات وجها لوجه في محاوله ربما لمعالجه
ازمه الولاءات بين الصين وروسيا واشنطن
اداره بيض اعتمدت وفقه مراقبين استراتيجيه
تخيير دول اسيا بينها وبين بكين ولتحقيق
المراد بتحجيم النفود الصيني المتزايده في
منطقه اسيا والمحيطين تسعى لاداره
الامريكيه الى تعزيز تعاون مع دول العشره
الاعضاء في رابطه اسيا الامر دفع ببيض
للمشاركه في القمه التي تعاقد سنويا والتي
غاب عنها سلفه ترامب منذ عام 2017
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه والتوتر بين
واشنطن والصين وازمه كوريا الشماليه ضغط
على قمه الاسيان التي تبحث وقضى اقتصاديه
فكانها مكانا الاجتماعات الامريكيه
يابانيه كوريه جنوبيه بحثت بتهديدات كوريا
الشماليه الصاروخيه والنوويه وتعاونها مع
روسيا بعد اسيان ستنتقل الانظار الى جزيره
بالي الاندونيسيه الاسبوع المقبل لقمه
مجموعه ال 20 والتي ستكون فيها الحرب
الاوكرانيه والعلاقات مع روسيا على راس
الاجنده الرئيس الاندلسي مصمم على انجاحها
ولتحقيقها دفه وجد نفسه مجبرا على القيام
برحله غير سهله اليك حيث سلمت دعوه حضور
القمه الى نظره الاوكراني بشكل شخص لينطلق
بعدها الى موسكو حاملا دعوه مماثله الى
الرئيس بوتين في جزيره بالي لم يكتب
اللقاء بين بيض وبوتين لكنه انذار
المراقبين ستتعلقه هناك حيث سيجمع لقاء
بين بيض والرئيس الصيني يتوقع ان يبحث
تنافس الاقتصادي وطلب امريكي من الصين
لاستخدام نفوتها على روسيا
تراجعي في اوكرانيا حنان المصري العربيه